my name is Jeff 1000 an evil robot from
outer space I'm just kidding I'm a
regular guy living in LA hanging out
with my best friend Summer Glau it's the
fun of sorry I'm still running Windows
95 there's a vengeful side to it so it's
kind of cold try this try it's just it's
what's beneath the surface right you got
it you can't just say it you've got to
actually mean it just take it's just
unlike human Dallaire accumulate but I
need only one here so you know I was
actually wondering about that too
you staying human alert but he's the
only robot yeah he's like warning
himself you know he's moody enough
because you're human and you hate humans
Jeff there's nothing you ain't more than
absolute 90% water a horrible human you
just want to annihilate that human and
that's what I'm not getting at right
yeah I'm gonna kill it but I did but
they just hate you let's try again yeah
okay I don't know is it the material oh
sorry one question I can't fly right I
need my character